A film’s plot is typically what makes or
breaks it, and audiences need to be entertained
or captivated by the basic story if it’s
to find success.
But sometimes there’s more going on than
what’s at face value.
Directors have long incorporated subtext into
their narratives to give movies an extra layer
to consider.
Make sure you rate your favorite entries in
the comments below and tell us if we missed
any!
Here are Screen Rant’s 10 Secret Meanings
Of Popular Films.
The Dark Knight
When faced by the Joker’s relentless attacks
on Gotham, Bruce Wayne sees what he must become
to stop villains like him and pulls out all
the stops.
The film’s climax is fueled by Batman’s
ability to monitor every cell phone in the
city so he can track the Joker’s location.
Some audience members may have been thinking
about the Patriot Act, which allows the US
government to search a person’s home and
records without consent to combat terrorism.
Some viewers have compared the film to George
W. Bush’s war on terror, as the former US
president took morally ambiguous means of
his own to fight the nation’s greatest threats.
Toy Story 3
Pixar’s emotional conclusion to their flagship
franchise could be more than a tale about
growing up.
Some see it as an allegory for the Holocaust,
with the toys representing the Jewish people
left behind at the start of WWII.
They go to the “concentration camp” of
Sunnyside Daycare and even end up on a path
to an incinerator due to the abuse of Sunnyside’s
overlords.
They’re eventually saved and find safe haven
in a new place where many of their kind already
live: Bonnie’s house.
It’s a tad dark for a family film, but the
parallels certainly are there.
X-Men
The X-Men films have always dealt with rights
issues, but here’s one you may have not
considered.
As mutant kind fights for their acceptance
in society, it’s easy to see how it relates
to the gay rights movement.
This point is put front and center in X2,
when Bobby Drake essentially “comes out
of the closet” and confesses his true nature
to his family, who immediately rejects him.
The angle arguably strengthens the series,
since it grounds the characters in a contemporary
real world struggle and makes them relatable
to audience members.
It’s inspiring to see people who are mutant
and proud.
The Lego Movie
Mocked upon its announcement, The LEGO Movie
turned heads and became one of 2014’s best
when it was released.
Many made note of the film’s deeper themes,
which poked fun at the idea of commercialism
vs. individualism.
Instead of being another faceless, regular
construction worker who follows the instructions
of his daily routine, Emmitt has to save the
world by thinking for himself and forming
his own ideas of what’s awesome.
His actions end up inspiring everyone around
him, even villain President Business.
It’s a great message for youngsters in the
audience, and gives adults substantial food
for thought as well.
E.T.
– The Extra Terrestrial
Spielberg showed with the Indiana Jones franchise
he’s not afraid to tackle religious elements,
and E.T. seems to feature those head on.
The Jewish director joked that it’s not
a Christian parable, but there are a lot of
parallels between ET and Jesus.
ET is “crucified” by scientists who don’t
understand him and is resurrected by Elliot’s
love.
Universal even made a poster that was reminiscent
of the Creation of Adam painting to make the
film appeal to Christian audiences.
Spielberg can claim that he never intended
the film to be viewed this way, but he provided
more than enough triggers.
The Matrix
The Matrix films are no stranger to philosophy,
and the influence could extend to Plato’s
cave.
That idea explores the notion of prisoners
in a cave whose only knowledge of the outside
world are shadows they see on the walls.
When they break free from their bonds, they
learn that what they perceived to be reality
is merely an illusion and there’s a whole
new world to explore.
One look at Neo’s character arc, it’s
easy to see how this comparison can be made.
Once the hero is unplugged, he learns the
truth about society and the elaborate hoax
the machines have played on us.
Groundhog Day
When weatherman Phil Connors is stuck in an
endless time loop during Groundhog Day in
Punxsutawney, his only way out is to change
his ways and become a more selfless individual.
Some have said that the film is an allegory
for the religious path to enlightenment and
learning to appreciate the things around you.
In this interpretation, the time loop represents
the state of purgatory, and one can escape
only when they’ve proven their worth to
a higher power.
Since we never learn the origin of the time
loop, this theory is as good as any for how
Phil got this way.
Aliens
The tagline for James Cameron’s beloved
sequel was “This time, it’s war,” and
the director may have meant more than humans
against xenomorphs.
Many, including Cameron, claim that Aliens
can operate as an allegory to the Vietnam
War.
Featuring a technologically advanced military
force that underestimates the capabilities
of the indigenous species on a mission with
questionable motives, it’s easy to see how
one can draw that comparison.
The space marines in the film even have a
gung-ho attitude that’s similar to conservative
America during the Vietnam War and think they’re
unstoppable, so there might be more here than
meets the eye.
Spider-Man
One of the most relatable superheroes, Spider-Man
has always been shown trying to overcome basic
problems that people face in their normal
lives.
In Sam Raimi’s original film, Peter Parker’s
evolution into the web slinger is seen as
a metaphor for puberty.
Socially awkward and going through some rough
physical changes, Peter learns how to adapt
and use his newfound abilities to better himself
and society.
He comes into his own and fully matures by
the film’s end, becoming the do-gooder we
all know and love.
With great power comes great responsibility,
and accepting those responsibilities is a
key step in growing up.
Who Framed Roger Rabbit
Robert Zemeckis’ technical marvel is more
than a world where humans and cartoons interact.
Some critics have claimed that the setting
is similar to segregated America, as the ‘toons
live in their own town that’s separated
from the human world.
The main plot could be derived from gentrification,
as Judge Doom looks to force the cartoons
out of their homes to build a freeway for
the wealthy class.
Finally, the cartoons are mostly seen as performers,
which was one of the accepted professions
for minorities at the time.
That adds a lot of intriguing context for
what should be a zany family adventure.
Those are our picks for hidden meanings in
popular movies.
Are there any we missed?
Which ones are your favorites?
Sound off in the comments section below and
be sure to subscribe to our YouTube channel
to watch more videos like this one!